in today's video we'll build a complete
web 3 application step by step from
scratch and in the process we'll talk
about the good and bad aspects of
developing decentralized web apps on the
blockchain you may have seen the
headlines of kids making millions of
dollars overnight by selling digital art
in the form of nfts if you're like me
and not already an nft millionaire you
likely have some fomo about this whole
trend you could point out how nfts are
dumb pointless and bad for the
environment or you could try to get in
on the trend yourself and that's exactly
what we'll do in this video i'll show
you how i created a collection of 20 000
unique graphics with some crappy artwork
i drew by hand in a few minutes we'll
then take that artwork and upload it to
the interplanetary file system at which
point we can write a smart contract with
solidity and open zeppelin that will
mint a new nft whenever somebody
transfers ethereum to the smart contract
and finally we'll use ether's js with
react to build a web3 application that
provides a front-end interface where
people can actually interact with a
smart contract by the end of this
tutorial you'll understand the complete
process of going from zero to a web 3.0
nft application this tutorial is longer
than most on this channel and it's
broken down into seven phases if you're
new here like and subscribe and follow
along with the full tutorial on fire
ship i o and if you want to see more web
free content let me know in the comments
before we get started let's first answer
the question of what is an nft
collection a non-fungible token is a
unique digital asset usually it
represents a piece of artwork like an
image but it can also represent things
like domain names and physical items in
the real world but you'll often see nfts
packaged in a collection like crypto
punks board ape yacht club and doodles
just to name a few these graphics are
created with a few base layers like hair
eyes clothing and so on the layers are
then combined together randomly to
create a bunch of unique graphics what's
interesting though is that the various
traits and attributes have different
levels of rarity when a graphic is
generated it's less likely to have one
of the rare traits this is actually
really fun because you can think of a
smart contract like a vending machine in
the cloud when an nft collection is
first offered you can send crypto to
that wallet address it will mint a
one-of-a-kind token and transfer it to
your wallet if you're lucky you'll get
something with a really rare trait it's
not much different than opening up a
pack of pokemon cards most of the cards
are very common but there is a small
chance you'll get something that's very
rare and valuable now after you purchase
an nft there's a secondary market where
you can resell it to someone else on a
site like openc many people invest in
nfts hoping to flip them for a higher
value later on if you're the original
creator you can also configure your
smart contract to receive royalty
payments whenever the nft changes hands
in the future that's pretty cool but
there are a lot of bad things i could
say about web3 as well the guy who
created signal an encrypted messaging
app created an nft that actually changes
its appearance based on where you view
it on openc it looks really cool but in
your wallet it looks like a piece of
poop because the nft image is hosted
off-chain he just used a web server to
display a different image based on the
user agent that was requesting the image
everybody talks about web3 being
decentralized and trustless but the
reality is that much of it works thanks
to centralized apis read this full blog
post to learn more at the end of the day
we don't really care about that we're
just here to have fun get some exercise
and make a ton of money now we're ready
to kick off phase one of this project
where we create the layers or graphics
that we'll use for the nft collection
i'm not much of an artist and everything
i draw tends to look really creepy not
much i can do about that so i'm just
gonna own it believe it or not creating
nft artwork is an art form i find it
really satisfying because you can take a
few basic images and use them to create
thousands of different unique
combinations for my nft collection i
actually used a pen and paper to draw
everything by hand i then digitized it
and brought each individual layer into
figma as you can see here i have
different categories for the various
traits like hair eyes nose mouth beard
and so on from there i created a little
script in node.js that randomly combines
these layers together you can find the
source code on github but there are many
existing tools out there that can help
you generate an nft collection without
needing to write any code if you're
looking for a tutorial that doesn't
require any code this is not the video
for you if your goal is to just create a
bunch of images and sell them as nfts
i'd recommend checking out this recent
tutorial from codestacker for a more
simplified approach i'm not going to go
through every single line of code here
but i just want to walk you through the
process i used to create all my nft
graphics from scratch first you can see
i have a directory called layers that
contains a bunch of files like i zero
eyes one eyes two and so on this
directory contains all the possible
layers that we would use in an image
from there i have a file named index.js
inside of it i have an svg template i'm
using scalable vector graphics here but
i've seen other implementations that
just use pngs now each layer in our
layers directory is an svg so all we
have to do is grab the main content from
that file and replace each one of these
comments with the corresponding graphic
like head hair eyes nose mouth and beard
in order to do that i'm using node.js to
read one of our layer files and then use
some regex to grab the content inside
the svg tags then i have a function
called create image that will generate a
bunch of random numbers and combine them
together into an array i've made this a
recursive function that checks to see if
that combination has already been taken
in which case it will try running the
randomization again if it is a valid
combination we'll go ahead and replace
all the comments in the svg template
with the actual layers from our layers
directory now in addition to creating an
image we're also going to create a json
file with some metadata about it this
metadata is really important because it
contains the name of the file as well as
a link to its actual image on the
interplanetary file system that
represents a unique file upload that
cannot be modified in addition the
metadata contains attributes of the
different traits in the image generally
when making an nft collection each trait
has a different level of rarity the more
rare traits an nft has the more valuable
it tends to be thanks to the magic of
artificial scarcity now i'll go ahead
and write these files to my file system
and as an added touch i'm also
converting the svg to a png file as well
i'm using a node package called sharp to
make that possible and finally to run
the script i just have a while loop that
calls the create image function for the
number of images that i want to create
and now when we run the script with node
we get this out directory with a bunch
of files that contain both the raw
images and json for each individual
graphic that takes care of phase one we
can now generate thousands or even
millions of individual graphics by
simply adding more layers to the layers
directory but keep in mind that my
implementation is very crude there's a
lot of optimizations we could make or
better yet we could have used a
pre-built solution out there to get this
job done much faster now the next thing
we need to think about is how to get
these files on the internet and connect
them to a non-fungible token the actual
image data and json for the nft is too
big to be efficiently stored on the
blockchain so instead we store an
off-chain on the interplanetary file
system which is a decentralized file
system in the cloud very similar to
bittorrent one very important concern
that ipfs handles is content
addressability anytime you upload a file
it creates a unique identifier for that
upload and that allows us to verify the
authenticity of any graphics associated
to an nft once a file has been uploaded
you can't modify it without changing its
content identifier that means when
minting an nft the only thing we
actually need to store is a link to that
file's content identifier now the
question becomes how do we take our raw
files and upload them to ipfs there are
many ways to go about it but an easy
free solution that i've been using is
pinata it's very similar to something
like dropbox where you simply click a
button to upload and choose a file from
your file system and you can even host
an entire static website from pinata it
also has a node sdk to upload
programmatically but we're not going to
worry about it in this video i'm just
going to upload a few of our images here
and you'll notice when i do that it
creates a content identifier
conveniently we can upload an entire
directory all at once i'm going to go
ahead and upload a few of the graphics
that i just generated for this tutorial
you can upload any random file it
doesn't really matter and now we're
ready to build a full stack web3
application using solidity hard hat and
react the first thing i'm doing here is
generating a new react app using veed it
really doesn't matter which end
framework you use here but the vast
majority of web3 demos out there use
react that gives us a front end
application now we're going to run npx
hard hat which will add a variety of
tools to our project to add a blockchain
backend you'll notice it generates a
directory for contracts which contains
files written in solidity which contains
the smart contract code that will
interact with the blockchain it also
creates a directory named scripts that
contains the code to deploy those
contracts to the blockchain now there's
a couple of configuration things we'll
need to do here in the hat config file
we'll update the paths option to create
any artifacts in the source directory
for the react application that allows
react to access information about the
smart contracts when you compile a smart
contract it creates what's known as an
application binary interface which is
basically a middleman that allows your
front-end javascript code to communicate
with the smart contract compiled to
machine code and all that information
lives in the artifacts directory from
there we're going to install a bunch of
dependencies with npm like waffle for
automated testing and ethers to interact
with smart contracts in the browser and
also a tool called open zeppelin which
provides templates for quickly building
industry standard smart contracts at
this point i want to focus on writing a
smart contract its purpose is to accept
a payment from a user then mint a
non-fungible token and transfer it to
that user's wallet it's important to
point out that the code in the smart
contract will not actually generate
random traits for the nft images it's
actually extremely difficult to handle
randomness in a smart contract most nft
collections don't deal with it at all
and instead they just generate all the
images at once upload them to ipfs and
then mint them after the fact at which
point they get sold on a secondary
market or you might code up another
contract to create your own secondary
market now it is possible to implement
randomness in a smart contract and if
that's what you want to do i would
highly recommend looking into something
like chain link we're going to take the
easy approach in this video where the
smart contract takes the ipfs url for
the metadata along with some ethereum
and mints a new token from it to handle
that requirement we'll need to learn a
new programming language called solidity
in the contracts directory let's go
ahead and create a file ending in dot
sol now we could implement a smart
contract from scratch but that would be
a pretty big undertaking on its own
luckily there's a tool called open
zeppelin and it has a wizard that we can
use to automatically generate reliable
code for us the ethereum ecosystem
already has a variety of standard
interfaces to handle requirements
commonly implemented in smart contracts
like erc20 is what you would use to
create a fungible token like if you
wanted to create your own coin on the
ethereum network but to create a
non-fungible token we want to use the
erc721 standard before we customize it
you'll notice that there is api
documentation with a handful of methods
built into the base contract like
balance of to check the owner's balance
or owner of to see who owns a token as
well as methods to transfer tokens from
one user to another now let's go over to
the open zeppelin wizard to customize
our own erc721 contract most importantly
we need to be able to mint our own
tokens if we check the box for mint it
adds a new method to the contract that
allows a privileged account to mint or
create a new token let's also auto
increment ids and then check the box for
uri storage uri storage allows us to
associate and upload on ipfs when this
token is minted remember that's the
reference to the metadata that we
uploaded on pinata earlier we'll also
want to use a base uri here that points
to ipfs to ensure that the uri is
properly formatted that gives us a base
contract to work with and you'll notice
a button here to open it up in the remix
ide i'm not going to do it in this video
but remix is a browser-based ide that
makes it really easy to compile and test
your smart contracts what we're going to
do is copy and paste this code and bring
it directly into the solidity file that
we created we could use this contract as
is but we want to extend it with some
additional code that allows anybody to
mint a token as long as they transfer
the appropriate amount of ethereum along
with it currently you'll notice a
safemint method that allows the owner of
the contract to mint a new token what we
want to do is create a new function
called payment it takes a recipient and
metadata content id then mint a new
token with that data now in order to
implement this function we'll want to
make sure that the same uri can't be
minted twice and to validate that i'm
creating a mapping of strings to
integers to keep track of the existing
uris that have been minted we might also
want to check if an existing uri is
already owned so i'm creating another
function called is content owned that
takes a uri as its argument and returns
true if that uri already exists in the
mapping now we have everything in place
to implement the payment function you'll
notice that it's marked as a payable
function which means that somebody can
transfer money into the contract now we
can use the require keyword to run some
validation and keep in mind that this is
not a production ready contract my goal
is just to show you how some of the
basic mechanics and solidity work with
require we first passed a condition in
this case we want to know if the uri has
already been minted if it has not been
minted the function will continue
executing otherwise it will throw an
error saying the nft has already been
minted the next thing we'll want to
validate is that the user has paid
enough ether there's a global variable
of message and its value property
contains the amount of ether being sent
into the contract we can make sure that
the minimum value is greater than .05
otherwise we'll throw an error saying
the user needs to pay up from there
we'll want to create a new item id with
the counter implemented by open zeppelin
it will increment each new token by 1 so
it starts at 0 then goes to 1 2 3 and so
on after incrementing the counter we'll
update our mapping of the existing uris
then we call the built-in mint method
with the recipient's wallet address and
finally we set the token uri on that id
that's how someone can pay to mint a new
token and as one final touch i'm also
going to add a function here to get the
current count so we can know exactly how
many tokens have been minted so far and
that completes the solidity code for our
back end at this point you may want to
just jump straight into building a web 3
application but i would highly recommend
that you do some testing first hardhat
already has a sample test ready to go
and the code you write in a test will be
very similar if not identical to the
code that you write in your frontend
react application it's much easier to
detect bugs and issues in a test than it
is in a front end application with all
the ui stuff going on if you've never
done test driven development before i
have an entire video on it in the test
we'll first use ethers to get our
contract and then deploy it once
deployed we'll then need a wallet
address with some ethernet for testing
luckily we can use a fake wallet with 10
000 ether in it already by going to the
terminal and running npx hard hat node
this creates a mock network on localhost
and provides us with a bunch of fake
accounts to use for testing copy one of
the public keys and use it in your test
at this point we can start calling the
methods on the deployed smart contract
first i'll create a variable called
balance that checks the current balance
of the recipient's wallet address
balance of is a method built into the
erc721 spec now currently the user
hasn't purchased any nfts so we expect
the balance to equal zero now from there
we'll create another variable called
newly minted token that calls the
payment method that we defined on the
smart contract it takes the recipient
and metadata uri as argument and then we
can also define the message value as .05
ether for fun let's go ahead and set the
ether value to 0.01 now go to the
terminal and run npx hard hat test what
you'll notice is that we get a failing
test and you'll see the error message
here that the user needs to pay up let's
go ahead and fix that and then we'll
wait for the newly minted token to be
mined by calling the wait method on it
from there we can query the balance
again and this time we expect it to
equal 1. in addition we can test our is
content owned method by making sure that
that metadata uri is equal to true and
there are all kinds of other things we
could test here but you get the general
idea if you test all your smart contract
logic first it'll make the front end
development much easier now we're ready
to move on to the next phase where we
build a web 3 application that interacts
with a smart contract from a website
let's first go into the sample script
provided by hardhat this script is used
to compile the contract which will
populate the artifacts directory with
all the information we need to interact
with it like the abi i talked about
earlier we'll want to update the default
values with the name of the custom
contract that we created you'll want to
first make sure you have a terminal
opened running the npx hard hat node
command this should always be running in
the background from there we can open up
a separate terminal and run npx hard hat
compile this runs the solidity compiler
to convert your code into binary once
that's done we can run npx hard hat run
scripts sample script and specify the
network as localhost that will take the
contract and deploy it to the actual
network and now we have a smart contract
running on our local machine now when it
comes to web3 the way end users interact
with a smart contract is typically with
a browser plugin like metamask for
development you'll want to set up
metamask with one of the testing
addresses provided by hardhat if you
don't have it yet install metamask and
then go to the localhost network and
import a new account it will ask you for
a private key which you can simply copy
from the terminal output and now we're
ready to start writing some react code
in order for a user to mint an nft on
the website they'll need to have meta
mask installed we'll need to check that
at runtime and have two different
screens based on whether or not it's
installed i'm creating two different
components here one called home and one
called install and in the install
component we'll simply have a link to
the metamask plugin now in the main app
component we can check to see if the
user has a plugin installed by checking
the window ethereum object a plugin like
metamask will make this object available
automatically when it's installed now
the next thing i'll do is create a new
component called wallet balance and
inside of it we can start interacting
with ethers.js which is a javascript
library that makes it easy to
communicate between the smart contract
and the end user's wallet in this
component what we want to do is get the
end user's current balance we'll first
set up state with the use state hook and
then define a function called get
balance we can get the connected account
on the window ethereum object and then
we use ethers.js to create a new web3
provider the provider provides all kinds
of different methods for interacting
with the blockchain one of which is get
balance which then takes the account as
its argument that will return the wallet
balance of the connected account which
should be 10 000 ether but it's in a big
number format so ethers also provides a
utility to format the ether value which
we can use when setting the balance on
the component and now we can call this
function when a button is clicked and
show the balance value in the ui now
let's go ahead and declare the wallet
balance component in the main component
and then we can serve the app locally by
running npm run dev i've also added
bootstrap to my project to make things
look a little nicer but the end result
should be a button that when clicked
updates the balance in the ui that's how
we can use ethers to interact with the
wallet but now how do we interact with
the smart contract we'll first need to
import the contract api from the
artifacts directory now earlier when you
compiled your contract and ran the
sample script it should have said
contract deployed to an address in the
terminal let's go ahead and take that
contract address and set it up as a
global variable here in our code we can
then instantiate a web3 provider again
and use it to get the signer to execute
transactions on the blockchain from
there we can use ethers to instantiate
the contract using the address the abi
and the signer what we want to do next
is loop over all the nft images in the
collection each one of those images will
have a button to mint it or if it's
already been minted the owner can view
the token uri for the nft we'll first
need to know how many tokens have
already been minted and to do that i'm
setting up a function here called git
count that calls the contract count
method that we implemented in solidity
earlier we'll then call this function
when the component is first initialized
with the use effect hook in the jsx i'm
looping over every token that's been
minted so far for each one of those
items i'm rendering a component called
nft image that takes the index as a prop
which conveniently matches the token id
now in the nft image component i'm
adding a property for the content id
this content id comes from pinata
remember i uploaded all my graphics to a
folder in pinata we can combine the
content id with the token id to
reference that json metadata uri now
when it comes to the actual image i
tried to use the pinata cloud gateway
but i didn't find this to be very
reliable i often had broken images so
currently i'm referencing my images here
locally now as we loop over these images
we need to figure out if each metadata
uri has been minted yet for that i'm
going to set up state on the component
of is minted and then define a function
called get minted status that will run
the iscontentone method on the smart
contract itself and then we'll run that
function with the use effect hook and
now we've reached the point where we can
actually mint the token i'm creating
another function to handle that and
inside the body the first thing it will
do is make a connection between the
contract and the signer that will give
us access to the recipient's wallet
address we then call the payment method
on the smart contract and pass the
address as well as the metadata uri as
argument in addition we need to set the
value of ether that the user will pay
for that we pass an object with a value
of the amount of ether which in this
case will be .05 you may notice how this
code is basically identical to the code
we wrote in our unit test earlier from
there we can wait for the result to be
mined after which point we can call the
get minted status function again and
this time it should say the metadata uri
has been minted now it's just a matter
of using some conditional logic in the
jsx to show the image uri if it's
already been minted otherwise we'll just
show a mystery placeholder and then
we'll also show the option to mint the
token if it's not already minted
otherwise it will say that nft is taken
now at this point if all went well you
should be able to go to the application
and when you click the mint button it
will bring up metamask confirming that
you want to transfer .05 ether and will
then complete the transaction after you
confirm it congratulations you just
built a basic web3 app let's take a
quick break to appreciate it
it's britney [ __ ] now we can move on to
phase seven deployment this app is by no
means production ready and it would cost
a lot of money to deploy it to the
ethereum main net but one thing we can
do is deploy it to a test net to see how
it would work in the real world a free
tool that can help us do that is alchemy
the majority of serious web 3
applications use tools like alchemy and
infuria which are platforms that can
help make decentralized apps more
reliable what we're going to do is use
alchemy to deploy our contract to a test
net when you create an account it will
give you the option to create a new
application and i'm going to use the
polygon chain with the polygon mumbai
network polygon by the way is a
blockchain built on top of ethereum that
is faster and less expensive its native
token matic is very similar to ether for
this tutorial you can think of matic and
ether as being the same basic thing once
the app is created you'll notice it
gives you a link to the network go ahead
and copy that now go back to the hard
hat config file in your source code
you'll need a new entry under networks
which in this case will be matic and
point it to the url that you just copied
the other thing you'll need is a private
key for your account go over to metamask
and switch the network to mumbai then
from the menu click account details and
export your private key then paste it
into the hard hat config the reason you
need a private key here is because this
account will be the one that deploys the
contract but deploying a contract isn't
free and currently there is zeromatic in
this wallet to get some free test money
we'll need to go to the polygon faucet
and add our public wallet address there
and after a few minutes of waiting you
should magically see some matic appear
in your wallet and now we're ready for
the moment of truth from the terminal
run the hard hat deploy script again but
this time make sure the network option
is set to matic that should deploy the
contract to the mumbai network make sure
to copy the address and update it in
your frontend code in the main.jsx file
you now have a web3 application running
out in the wild and you could follow the
same basic process to deploy to the main
net i'm going to go ahead and wrap
things up there hopefully that gives you
a general idea of all the steps involved
in building a dap the final thing i'll
mention is that if you want to purchase
these nfts yourself you can do so on
openc i don't know why you ever would
but they're there if you want them
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next one